spy tactics has had a great alpha stage
and we really appreciate all the
feedback we've gone for you guys we're
very happy to announce that starting
right now smite tactics is moving into
its closed beta smite tactics is a
unique take on the smite universe it is
a turn-based strategy game where you
create a deck based on a Pantheon and
the synergies inside of it just like
previous titles at hi-rez Studios we're
starting off our closed beta and tactics
with the founder's pack and the
founder's pack provides immediate access
into the beta along with access to the
beta you also get 15 card packs of 5
cards each legendary leaders Poseidon
Isis and Freya and the legendary God in
you you also get one exclusive founders
icon and one exclusive founders card
back not only do you get this content in
smite tactics but also in smite get the
exclusive skin in yo and the exclusive
tactics loading frame now this in your
skin is special because it marks the
first time in smites history that we've
done the Greek pantheon version of a
Roman God and not only is it a skin in
smite but it also is a playable unique
God and smite tactics we had a very
successful closed alpha and we're
excited to get into the closed beta
stage it's been a lot of fun to put a
new spin on the smite characters and
tactics and there's a lot more coming at
January this is a closed beta that we're
starting so there's gonna be a lot of
changes a lot of new content and a lot
of surprises coming up with let next
couple months we're very excited for you
guys to take the ride along with us
[Music]